the door of number 10 downing street is
one of the great symbols of our
democracy
those who live behind it exercise great
power
but they do so knowing their stay is
temporary
long after they've gone
that door and the democracy it
represents
will remain firm and unyielding
but britain's constitution is fragile it
relies on members of this house and the
custodians of number 10 behaving
responsibly
honestly
and in the interests of the british
people
when our leaders fall short of these
standards this house has to adapt
for months members opposite have asked
the country to wait first for the police
investigation which concluded
that this prime minister is the first in
our country's history to have broken the
law in office
then they asked the country to wait for
the sue grey report
they need weight no longer
that report lays bare the rot that under
this prime minister has spread in number
10
and it provides definitive proof of how
those within the building
treated the sacrifices of the british
people
with utter contempt
[Music]
[Applause]
when the dust settles and the anger
subsides
this report will stand as a monument to
the hubris and the arrogance of a
government
that believed it was run wool for them
and another rule for everyone else
the details are stark
five months ago the prime minister told
this house all guidance was completely
followed in number 10.
yet we now know he attended events on
the 17th of december
at least one of those attending has
received a fine for it deeming it
illegal we know that on the 18th of
december an event was held in which
staff drank excessively which others in
the building described as a party
and the cleaners were left to mop up the
red wine the next day
on the 20th of may
as a covered press conference was taking
place
one of his senior officials was told be
mindful
cameras are leaving
don't walk about waving bottles
it is now impossible to defend the prime
minister's words to this house
this is about trust
because during that may 20 press
conference the british public were told
normal life as we know it is a long way
off
but that wasn't the case in number 10.
[Music]
even now after 126 fines
they think it's everyone else's fault
but theirs
they expect others to take the blame
whilst they cling on
they pretend that the prime minister has
somehow been exonerated
as if the fact that he only broke the
law once is worthy of praise
the truth is
they set the bar for his conduct
lower than a snake's belly
and now they expect the rest of us to
congratulate him as he stumbles over it
number 10 symbolizes the principles of
public life in this country selflessness
integrity objectivity accountability
openness
honesty
leadership
but who could read this report and
honestly believe the prime minister has
upheld those standards
the reason the british public have had
to endure this pass was his refusal to
admit the truth
or do the decent thing when he was found
to have broken the law
this report was necessary
because of what sue grey describes as
failures of leadership and judgment
for which senior political leadership
must bear responsibility
it is that failure of leadership that
has now left his government paralyzed in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
the government has turned the focus of
his government
to saving his own skin
it's utterly shameful
it is precisely because he cannot lead
that it falls to others to do so
i've been clear
what leadership looks like
[Applause]
i haven't broken any rules and any
attempt
any attempt to comply
sorry
can i just
calm it down quite rightly i wanted to
the prime minister i expect the same of
the leader of the opposition now those
who don't wish to hear you please go and
have a cup of tea or something
i've been clear what leadership looks
like
i haven't broken any rules and any
attempt to compare a perfectly legal
takeaway while working to this catalogue
of criminality looks even more
ridiculous today
but mr speaker
if the police decide otherwise
i will do the decent thing
and step down
the public need to know that not all
politicians are the same
that not all politicians put themselves
above their country
that honesty integrity and
accountability matter
members on the opposite benches now also
need to show leadership
[Music]
this prime minister is steering the
country in the wrong direction
they can hide in the backseat eyes
covered praying for a miracle
or they can act
stop this out of touch out of control
prime minister from driving britain
towards disaster
we waited for the sugray report
the country can't wait any longer the
value symbolized by the door of number
10 must be restored
members opposite must finally do their
bit
they must tell the current inhabitant
their leader
that this has gone on too long
the game is up you cannot be a lawmaker
and a law breaker
and it's it's time to pack his bags
only then can the government function
again
only then can the rot be carved out
only then can we restore the dignity of
that great office
and the democracy that it represents